all right team here we go have a quick
some roam rats be careful alright first
floor is all boarded up
you know we face these guys before all
right my drone spawn in the second floor
got one that just passed me it looks
like we got three more in the hallway
they're reinforcing the kids room wall
right there they're blocking the master
bedroom looks like she's blocking the
main entrance I see the hostage she's in
the kids room
periquito we list
[ __ ] hey Sami drones out okay I say we
breach the garage no I'd rather not
I mean they always defend it with a
shitload of booby traps mmm I say we
drop in the roof and breach the three
second-floor windows we all come in at
once what do you guys think okay yeah
that sounds good principle free
helicopter drop Roger that
now fire oh and I'll take the large
window you guys take the rest you got it
yep go gotcha
you guys you did wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait what you all right yeah
yeah all good all right set up it on
three one two three yeah I'll get her
okay
outside [ __ ] okay you stay here okay the
floor okay let's go I see him I see him
okay
and windows locks
sorry guys releasing the hostage I mean
don't worry about it
wait but listen watch out for havoc he's
still out there there there he's right
there yeah he's outside Rath watch out
looking look at the timer no time to
waste let's go yeah you're right it's
getting louder
yeah or close hang on wait wait listen
the drone alright alright uh hostages on
the ground through the door
other door in the wall reinforced the
door upstairs is barricaded one just
grabbed her [ __ ] this loser is a shield
the other ones got a shield - they're
facing the door right get ready to
breach what are you thinking I don't get
them above us wrath you still on the
north side yeah
alright I'm making a door in the living
room
yes all right I gotta lay this didn't
cover me got you what where is he
it's never mind that hurry box taking
Dante ready when you are
okay okay I'm gonna breach the ceiling
just wait for my go got it come on Dante
breaching cool I got her
yes nice one guys let's get out I move
it upstairs don't get surprised all
right let's go here we go find an exit
I'm okay everything is blocked clear one
out all right I'm taking out the main
entrance
all right I got the window
[Music]